in a revealing interview on face the
nation dr deborah burke said that there
were
covet deniers inside the trump white
house
she told margaret brennan that she knew
accepting the role of white house
coronavirus response coordinator
would probably lead to the end of her
career in the federal government
were there coveted deniers in the white
house
there are people in the white house and
i think people around this country
because i've had the privilege to meet
them
and listen to them and hear them because
i wanted to hear what people were saying
there were people who definitely
believed
that this was a hoax why
i think because the information was
confusing at the beginning
i think because we didn't talk about the
spectrum of disease
because everyone interpreted on what
they knew and so they saw people get
coveted
and be fine so you don't blame the
president's own language of calling some
of this politically motivated a hoax
it was a phrase he used at one point
when you have a pandemic where
you're relying on every american to
change their behavior
communication is absolutely key
and so every time a a statement was made
by a political leader
that wasn't consistent with public
health
needs that derailed our response
and this will be the end of your federal
career yeah i will um need to retire
probably within the next four to six
weeks from cdc
and how have you made peace with that
that this
pandemic that you're leaving in the
midst of this
that you will be associated with it what
was reassuring to me all along
is i knew this would be studied i knew
that the emails the reports that i wrote
the request to expand testing
the how to improve therapeutics
all of that all of that
would eventually come to light yeah it
sounds like
dr deborah burks was keeping receipts as
they say face the nation moderator
margaret brennan
joins us now with more on the story
margaret i have to say i sat there at my
kitchen table
my jaw dropped and my heart dropped as i
watched that interview with dr debra
burks i've never seen anything like it
kudos to you
for engaging her in that way i think
many people watching
thought that she was in between a rock
and a hard place
and the more she talked the more you
could see that that was true but she
clearly wanted to set the record
straight on her behalf
did she not she did
you know i think all of us are going
through this national trauma and trying
to process this pandemic and for those
on the front lines who were in the
middle of this
in the chaotic response they're still
trying to process what they went through
too dr burke
certainly is we talked to her about that
at length
and i think one of the more troubling
things was to hear from someone who had
dedicated her entire professional career
to dealing with pandemics around the
world aids in sub-saharan africa
was brought to her knees here in the u.s
by a health care system that that leads
the way in medical innovation
and wealth but couldn't get out of its
own way
in dealing with this pandemic that she
uh
really was crippled she felt by the
chaos inside the white house
but also as she emphasized time and
again
this wasn't just a leadership and
personality failure and and she lays
blame
uh at the white house for a lot of that
but also systematic failures
within our healthcare infrastructure and
those are the things i think
particularly for the medical
professionals that they are raising red
flags about she certainly was here that
there is a lot of
accounting to do with the cdc and other
agencies
so that we don't get hit the next time
by the next pandemic the way we are
still
struggling now you know what struck me
is when she talked about the parallel
streams of information that were coming
that she would often
have to do an end run to go directly to
the governors almost saying
forget what you're hearing up here
please listen to what i'm telling you
down here
i'd with someone that had the sterling
reputation that she did how frustrating
that had to be
for her absolutely
and it confirmed so much of the
reporting to this point that we've had
that we know
also i mean this was something that for
the president and those around him
this was a pattern of behavior to use
almost wishful thinking to drive policy
making to
turn not to the best institutional
experts from the inside of the
government but to pick and choose data
from those who might be more consistent
with your point of view
and sometimes the facts aren't always in
your favor or
favorable uh and so for someone who's
driven by science and data that's
that's inconceivable uh to her
and that's what she was expressing and i
think hearing
each week that she and a team were
crunching these numbers
sending it out to governors warning them
about what was happening in their states
and she doesn't even know if the reports
were read by the president
she doesn't know even if the vice
president read them but she knows they
were sent to her boss
mike pence by the way who ran that
coveted response
uh and and his staff says they the staff
read them but they can't confirm that
the vice
president read each and every one
margaret dr dr burke said that
she constantly considered quitting why
didn't she
you know anthony this is the question
that i keep hearing certainly in my
social media feed there's so much anger
uh at people like dr burks and others
who sat on that covert
team who for i don't know what people
want exactly perhaps to storm out and
say
i quit but this is something that we
hear
constantly from the civil servants the
people who aren't
necessarily at the stature of a dr fauci
who ran his own institution
who couldn't be fired who has spoken
openly about it being conflicted himself
but that they felt well if i leave
what happens next and that's why i did
ask her
well did you make a difference did
staying make a difference
she believes she did but this is
something that i think
uh so many of the people on the inside
are going to
to struggle with themselves but for
the public i understand the anger i
think
for us as journalists it's very much
worth hearing
from people who are on the front lines
so we can better understand
exactly what was happening that's why
the interview was so good margaret
because you really took us on the inside
jerome adams tweeted this the former
surgeon general people so freely suggest
they would have left but hold the one
woman in the room to a different
standard
do you think that's true she was held to
a different standard because she was a
woman i thought that was an interesting
observation
i thought that was too from the former
surgeon general and
he pointed out he felt he was being held
to a different standard as well
that for him in that those tweets uh he
was the only person of color on that
coveted response team she was the only
woman
i don't know but i do know that um
it is worth asking that question of
you know why do we give forgiveness for
some and condemn the others and i think
that broader point
of not associating civil servants with
politics
is important because we need the experts
to help us
in moments of crisis well for those who
didn't see it i highly recommend it
it was extraordinary margaret and that's
no exaggeration she talked about
told taking on her personal life really
great great job thank you